كيف سيكون رد موسكو على قرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومجموعه الدول السبع واستراليا
وتعسقف لسعر النفط الروسي المنقول بحرا
عند 60 دولارا للبرميل سيندمون على قرارهم
قال مسؤولون روس في حين قال المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الروسيه ان موسكو تحتاج الى تحليل
الموقف قبل تجهيز رد لكنها لا تقبل وضع
سقف لسعر خامها تنتقد روسيا وتصفيه باعاده
تشكيل مبادئ السوق الحره وتبدو خياراتها
في تعزيز وجهات اخرى فصدره مسك النفطيه
المنقوله بحرا الى القاره الاسيويه ارتفعت
بنحو واحد 31% على اساس سنويا في الاشهر
الماضيه من هذا العام
من الصين والهند وهما المستفيدتان من
خصومه موسكو على مشتريتهم اضافه الى تركيا
على نحو 41% اجمالا من صادرات النفط
الروسيه عام 2022
وبينما يرى بعض المحللين ان كلا من
نيودلهي وبيجين وانقر قد لا تقدم على
زياده احجام شحنه النفط من موسكو دون
تخفيضات اكبر للاسعار باعتبار الضرف فرصه
لهم بدات تصريح وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرجي لابروفيست سباق لذلك حينما
قال حين الاهم ليس سقف السعر المقترح
بالتفاوض المباشر مع الشركاء لكن ثمه
مشكله تتعلق بالشحن مع تقلص محتمل في حجم
الاسطول المتاح لنقل النفط الروسيه مع
خساره السفن الاوروبيه فعاده ما يستغرق
شحن النفط الخام البحر البلطيق الى الهند
السفن ما لا يقل عن اربعه اضعاف مده تسليم
الشحنات الى روستردام ونقل الحجم نفسه
سيتطلب اربعه اضعاف عدد السفن
يقول محللون ان روسيا يمكنها ايضا ان تلجا
الى مخططات مثل نقل النفط من سفينه الى
اخرى لاخفاء اصولها وخلط نفسها بانواع
اخرى لالتفاف على الحظر اما الكسندر
نوفاكنه رئيس الوزراء الروسي فقال لن
نتعامل بموجب سقف اسعار النفط حتى ان
تطردنا الى خفض الانتاج خفضا قد تكون له
تابعات في سوق الطاقه العالميه فمحلل مصرف
دي انبي يرون ان هناك حاله كبيره من عدم
اليقين بشان تاثير المحتمل للاجراءات
الغربيه على المعروض الروسيه
للالتفاف على هذه التدابير باستخدام نفوذ
روسيا داخل اوبن كلاس مع توقعاته بانتعاش
سعر النفط الخام فوق عتبه المئه دولار
للبرميل في الشهور المقبله